今日は
あるですイベントイングですねイベントイングな感じでね
今閣下が各家じゃないほうのステージの裏に来てるんですけどもうひとがたくさん入っ
ているらしいです
これでもうすぐ始まるので
緊張しています
お待たせしましたアラサーっやテーマが集めちゃおうじゃないですよ
でもって
写真撮影動画たぜを受け入れみんなああ
うわぁはまだまだ肯定してないですよはじめ者と言うじゃ元旦なさーーん
わーそれではあなたとどうぞよろしくお願いしまーす
tar
car
ああああああ
goo
rar
やっぱり関西をすごい
ちょっとボってさっきもなんか流れて撮ったと思うんですけどとニックさんをちょっと
いじる
いないかの動画を撮ったんですけどもなんか普段絶対会えば少女取れないんですごい
いい体験をさせてもらったと思いますありがとうございます今回は前回に続いて
をはじめらの時代がき動画見た人はい
a year でいいでならそれ一さんよりこちらの cm どうですか
なんかほんとに何か自分で見ても大変なことになったなぁと思って持つとがすごいこと
になってたんですよ
twitter で集めた質問をいくつかその中からピックアップ
したので肇社長で応対していただきたいと思います
まず一番多かった質問かわいいですかお前動画の撮影と編集に利益してどれくらいの
時間をかけているかという事ですよ
皆さんいかがでしょ本当に動画によって全然変わるんですけど長いのだったらもう50
などが6時間とか1日かかってもできないん
はちょっと思ったな
11限られてるんですけどなあなあ1か月もあれば
の1時間
かからないぐらいでできるのもあるのでみんな意外とするっあっ
た通りお母さんに一番怒られた動画を教えてくださいデコだろ
cm は最後にオマージュさんおっしゃってますよ実際に置かずに怒られたこととあり
ますかでしょっちゅう動画だしたと line とかで怒られるんですよ
家納言チャレンジってわかりますみたいなあーっ
別なおすっ
でワーッと不安定の両自なんですけどやっぱちょっと危ないらしくて
お母様に通報するぞと言われます
参加されたみなさーん同写真撮影
ran
ni
voodoo どうしますあそうそう
other でそれでそれで
前よりださぁ行けるかなぁ
こちらでだ会で12
封書ジャージャーですねっ
水のポーズ決めてるだそれ
はいありがとうございますキャッシュ
はいみなさん今日は足元が悪い中お越しいただき誠にありがとうございます京都に来る
9番街いなかったんですけど久しぶりに入ってとてもいいあのん
また記載があるものに入っている終わるデー
re 場はぁ
皆様また会える日があれば是非ん
ありましょういい
0なんでー
ハーイございまーす
ありがとう
ああああああああ
ああああああ
アンポスターやチームを覚えですうううう
思いません
モッツアレラチーズはぁ
何でもしてくれる